well needless to say the big social
media story of the week is Elon musk's
release of internal emails and documents
at Twitter proving beyond a shadow of a
doubt that big Tech has been censoring
and suppressing information at the
behest of political campaigns in order
to influence the outcome of Elections
and for other reasons just as nefarious
we'll talk more about all that in a few
minutes there's another social media
story that has caught my attention
though
as well it may not have the same
political implications but it points to
what I think is an even bigger problem
in fact a much bigger problem reading
from the Independent it says the Fatal
Blackout Challenge on Tick Tock has
reportedly been linked to the deaths of
at least 20 children in the past 18
months the popular Challenge on the
social media platform encourages people
to choke themselves with household items
until they become unconscious and then
film the adrenaline rush once they
regain Consciousness at least 15 of
those children who died while filming
the challenge were aged 12 or younger
according to data compiled by Bloomberg
businessweek five of the victims were
aged 13 or 14. the Blackout Challenge is
a modern incarnation of choking dares
that have been around for years but have
been made more accessible to Children
through social media platforms the
choking game quote unquote killed 82
miners when it first appeared in 2008
according to data from the CDC Tick Tock
and its parent company bite dance have
been sued by parents who claimed their
children died as a result of the Fatal
challenge
now Bloomberg goes into more uh detail
about one of the victims and one of
these stories and it is as you might
expect horrific
it begins the five-year-old boys
panicked cries echoed down the hallway
of the Arroyo's three-bedroom clapboard
house in Milwaukee it was February 2021
and he'd been playing with his
nine-year-old sister ariani before
bedtime their mother was at a Bible
study class and their father was in his
basement Workshop out of earshot the boy
had watched Ariana climb atop a toy
chest wrap a metal dog leash around her
neck and hook the Buckle to the Wardrobe
door hinge now she was hanging two feet
from the ground kicking and desperately
scratching at her neck
a few days later after Ariana was buried
wearing a princess dress in Tiara her
nails freshly painted the boy told his
parents what had happened they were
playing a game he said like they saw in
tick tock
now this is of course just the latest
dangerous Trend to spread through uh to
spread to kids through social media
platforms like Tick Tock every week it
seems there's another one and it's not
as though as the first article mentions
not as though kids weren't doing
hideously stupid and dangerous things
before the internet existed the Blackout
Challenge itself predates social media
but social media spreads these ideas at
the speed of light not only spreads them
it provides enormous additional
incentive for kids to participate in
them because now they can do it for the
likes and the shares and the views
and also when they're doing these uh
Stupid Reckless things not knowing that
they're stupid and Reckless they're
often going to be isolated by themselves
while they're doing it
and they do it wife again for the hope
the dopamine hit that they get from all
the attention attention that comes in
measurable quantities that they can see
and speaking of measurable quantities
the impact of the internet and social
media on children obviously goes Way
Beyond Reckless and sometimes deadly
challenged Trends on Tick Tock kids
today are more depressed more anxious
they suffer more from mental illness
they're more suicidal than any
generation of children before them in
history they're also fatter less healthy
more isolated they spend less time
outside they spend less time
participating in group activities they
spend less time with sports they have
fewer real life friends they have worse
social skills
and there are many factors contributing
to this but nearly all of the research
and also just basic Common Sense points
to one thing as by far the biggest
factor and that is their phones the
internet social media
the average kid over the age of 13
spends nearly 10 hours a day staring at
various screens and that's just
recreational screen time it doesn't even
take into account the time spent using
screens for school work or homework
so when all said and done each day
there's barely any time left for
anything that doesn't involve looking at
a glowing rectangle
this is their life
and and we have barely begun to
contemplate and confront the
consequences
of a life lived like this so young
in fact most adults don't seem to be
contemplating it at all according to a
survey a few years ago
and these numbers have probably all
gotten worse as they as that's what the
trends indicate
a few years ago the vast majority of
kids were given their first cell phone
before the age of 13.
and nearly 40 percent have a phone
before they turn 10. and nearly 20
percent have a phone by the age of eight
about 10 of a phone by six
there is even a not insignificant
portion of three-year-olds who are given
smartphones three-year-olds
I mean the best we can say about kids
who are given this kind of technology so
young is that they'll become very good
at using the technology but that's not
saying much as smartphones are not
difficult to use we don't call them
smartphones because you need to be smart
to use them quite the opposite effect
they can be mastered in about five
minutes even by someone who's never held
one before there's a reason why a
three-year-old can figure out how to use
it
so it's not like you need to get them on
it early so they'll know how to keep up
with a technology-based society
you could never hand your your kid a
phone until they turn 18 and they'll
have it figured out
by lunchtime
and for the sake of getting our kids up
to speed on the latest technology the
cost is that their chance of depression
mental illness suicide obesity isolation
exposure to grotesque and harmful images
like hardcore pornography all of that
skyrockets
they will become overstimulated easily
bored in need of constant distraction
and entertainment
a problem that will then often be solved
by psychotropic medication
they will become Dumber less interesting
people than they otherwise would have
been
but at least they'll be able to type
really quickly with their thumbs now the
message is that they're typing with
their thumbs will be inane and
semi-literate even into adulthood but
they'll learn to say them very fast
they're gonna learn to say really stupid
things quickly that's the benefit
so what's the solution here well an
unlikely person has stepped into that
conversation the actress Kate Winslet
got some attention this past week uh
while promoting her new film which
apparently deals with social media
addiction among children and she called
for uh the government to get involved
let's listen to this
do you think there needs to be more
regulation I mean should we just say
social media shouldn't be available to
people under a certain age or what might
be the answer
it's a difficult one because when you're
an individual in something of a high
profile position you know we do have to
be careful that we're using our voices
wisely hopefully telling stories that
resonate speaking with integrity and and
and leading with the truth those things
are very important to me
I really do struggle with social media
um I struggle with the impact it's
clearly having on teenage mental health
I do wish that our government would
crack down on it I do wish that there
would be certain platforms that were
banned before a certain age I wish that
security checks would be much more
rigorous
um you know teenagers
where there's a will there's a way so if
they want to get on that platform they
will but I do believe that there needs
to be a lot more protection and
accountability because parents are left
flailing going well thank you so much
government look what just happened to my
child
now later on she says that parents feel
utterly powerless to help their kids
overcome their social media obsession
which is why she says the government has
to step in and uh and she's not wrong I
mean the law cannot solve the problem on
its own but it can at least do something
whereas now it's doing nothing at all
there should be laws Banning Social
Media companies from allowing minors on
their platform that should exist now the
harm that social media does to the
developing minds of children it's clear
enough to anyone willing to look
but we don't need to spend another 15
years sitting around hoping that it will
work itself out in the end
we know all that we need to know right
now to justify taking action drastic
action
how can social media companies prevent
kids from using their services well not
perfectly but they can do more than
they're doing now because again right
now they're doing nothing so anything at
all would be better than the nothing
that they're doing
as it stands Tick Tock welcomes all kids
ages 13 and over
so they're not they're not even trying
to stop 13 year olds because they're
they're welcome 13 13 year olds to use
it
so the age limit by law should be moved
up to 18.
and they should be required to take
steps to ensure however imperfectly that
the age limit is respected this is
possible you know there are websites
like you want to use a gambling website
for example you have to take now there
are ways around that even then but there
are steps that have to be taken to
verify your age
if we were really serious though we
would actually have laws Banning anyone
under the age age of 18 from owning a
smartphone in the first place
um now this idea
only seems over the top and shocking to
people today because we ourselves are
Mindless phone addicted zombies and we
cannot imagine a life apart from our
beloved devices so even the adults when
we hear that well Banning minors we it's
like we can't even conceive of that
because we again cannot conceive of what
what it means to live without this stuff
but there is no god-given constitutional
right to a smartphone especially not for
minors
and we know that smartphones are
addictive and they're harmful on every
conceivable level
so what exactly is the argument for not
Banning their sale to children
like what's the argument for allowing
Apple to smoke to sell iPhones
to kids
no child has ever been harmed by not
having a phone with internet connection
that's ever happened
many many millions of children have been
harmed by having it so
what seems Unthinkable to unthinking
Americans Banning smartphones outright
for minors is in fact the obviously
correct course of action
it's obviously the right thing to do
which is why it will never happen
so we're left then with the other
obvious solution although it too is only
a partial solution
and that is for parents to step up and
start taking the issue seriously
um
you know you give your kid a smartphone
because it's the easiest thing to do
because it keeps them quiet keeps them
entertained
because all of his friends have one
because he says that if you don't give
him one he's going to hate you
because you feel powerless to do
anything different as Kate Winslet says
but you're not powerless
I mean you're the parent it's your money
it's your house
you hold all the cards you have all the
power all the Leverage
your kid has none
your child will not volunteer to
radically depart from his peers by
living a phone free life
even if it's the life that every kid on
earth lived up until the last couple of
decades it now seems radical and
unthinkable
he's not going to volunteer for that
which is why you can't follow his cues
on this
you have to take the lead
which means taking the phone away
it is a problem if it's that that seems
if any of this seems extreme well the
problem is Extreme
again we cannot even fully conceive we
know about so much of the damage but we
cannot fully conceive of what it will be
like
to eventually have a society filled with
people who have been on these devices
and addicted to them practically from
birth
and here's the thing you take the phone
away from me can I guarantee once he's
older he's not going to look back on his
childhood and wish that he'd spent more
time on his phone
no one wishes that
none of us on our Death Beds are going
to look back and say you know what my
one regret is that I didn't spend more
time staring at that damn thing
your kid's not going to regret it you're
not going to regret it for him you're
not gonna look back and say well man I
only wish I just wish I had put him on
the phone earlier
no he will thank you eventually from
saving for saving him from becoming a
fat depressed zombie like all of his
peers
even if he hates you in the meantime
but that's a price worth paying
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]